Let us look at the details of constraint propagation. To do so,
we'll take a specific example from computer vision. Here's an example of a 2D
image composed of a large number of pixels. The greyness at any one pixel
is a depiction of the intensity of light at that pixel. Now of course, you and
can immediately recognize that this is a cube. But how do we do it, and
how can we make a machine do it? [UNKNOWN] decompose a task of 3D object
recognition into several several sub-tasks. Miles said in the first sub-task,
a visual system detects edges, or lines as shown here. At this particular point,
no surfaces have been detected. In this particular point, no 3D object has been
fignized. Just these pixels have been put into lines based on the intensities
of light in different pixels. According to Miles the second sub task of object
recognition consists of grouping these lines and the surfaces with orientations,
as indicated here. So now these four lines have been grouped into the surface,
and then orientation defined by the perpendicular the surface, and
similarly these four lines, and these four lines. In the third and
final phase of the object recognition task, according to Miles surfaces
are grouped into a complete 3D object. At this particular point,
your visual system recognizes that this is a cube. Miles theory has been
very influential in computer vision. It has actually also been influential in AI
as a whole. One of the lessons we can take away from Miles' theory of computer
vision of object's recognition is that before we get into our guarded tones for
addressing the task, we want to understand how a task gets decomposed into sub
tasks. Throughout this course, we have emphasized task decomposition repeatedly.
As an example, when we were talking about understanding,
a big task of understanding got decomposed into a series of small tasks.
Where surface level cues acted as probes into memory and
a frame was retrieved. The slice of the frames dented expectations.
Lexicon and grammatical analysts led to the identification of objects and
predicates that would satisfy those expectations. And the fillers were put in.
Problem reduction certainly is a general purpose method for decomposing complex
tasks into smaller tasks. This notion of class decomposition is a powerful
idea irrespective of what algorithm we use for any of these specific sub tasks